So, we're looking for Katrina's speed alone, that would be without the current.
We know when she goes upriver or upstream, she goes 15 miles. So this distance
is 15. She has to come back to her original starting point, so that means she
has to go another 15 miles. To get back where she started. That would be her
distance downstream. We know the speed of the current is 5 miles per hour, but
we don't know Katrina's speed. It's x. So, if Katrina is travelling downstream,
she travels faster. So that would be x which is our speed plus the current
which is 5. If Katrina is traveling upstream she's fighting the current, so
she's going slower. So that would be x minus 5. Whenever we work with these
motion problems and a current. We'll always add or subtract the current to
whatever speed our person or object is going. So in this case Katrina's speed
was x. So we need to add the current for her downstream speed and subtract the
current for her upstream speed. Now we're ready to find expressions for the
time. We know the time is distance divided by rate. So going upstream we'll
have 15 divided by x minus 5. And going down stream we'll have 15 divided by
the quantity x plus 5. Now this was pretty tough, so if you got at least part
of this right, great work.